[Music]
the following is a production of New
Mexico State University
[Music]
with the dawn of every harvest season
comes the influx of invasive weeds and
insects to the Navajo Nation these pests
invade and Destroy healthy productive
crops sometimes pest population control
is a necessary step to assure that crops
survive and are as plentiful as
possible natural enemies will take care
of some of the pests but the rest is up
to the farmer timely crop r ation
removal of the food that pests eat and
planning the timing of planting growing
and harvesting will get rid of some of
these pests but pesticides are often
still needed to achieve economic control
the single most important step in using
pesticides is to always read the label
and follow the directions on the label
exactly you are responsible by law for
any damage caused by pesticides to
people or property by reading the label
on the pesticide container you will have
all the inform information you need to
protect yourself and
others first determine the pest you need
to control and which chemical is best
fit to control it selective pesticides
will kill only the weed or insect that
is its Target non-selective pesticides
can kill more than just the
target there are many different types of
pesticides each is named based on the
pest it is designed to
control once the type of pesticide is
determined the formulation can be
selected formulations are either liquid
or dry there are four types of liquid
formulations solutions are one
formulation that comes ready for use and
require special application equipment
flowables must be mixed with
water aerosols in low concentration are
often used indoors as a fine spray or
Mist liquefied gas fumigants turn into
gas when applied some are packed in
pressure containers but before
attempting to use any of these
pesticides be sure and read and
understand all the instruction on the
label pesticide labels include the
following information how to use the
product correctly and safely the brand
name and the type of
formulation active ingredients will be
listed by common name and by chemical
name all other non-active ingredients
will also be listed net contents and the
manufacturer of the product will be
named it is critical when using a
pesticide that you are aware of its
toxicity the label will indicate if the
pesticide is highly toxic moderately
toxic or if it is a less toxic
formulation essential first aid and
physici information for pesticide
poisoning treatment is contained on the
label in case of an accidental poisoning
the labels also indicate which pests
will be controlled and how where and
when the pesticide is to be applied
again it is illegal to use any pesticide
if you do not follow the instructions on
the label there are a few simple but
important safety measures you must take
to protect yourself when using
pesticides make sure your body is fully
covered and that you are wearing
neoprene gloves these gloves should be
long enough to protect your wrists shirt
sleeves should be outside your gloves to
keep pesticides off your hands cotton
gloves are dangerous unless the
pesticide label indicates otherwise wear
long- sleeve shirts pants and coveralls
that will fit outside your gloves and
boots to protect from
spills goggles or a face shield are also
necessary protection when using
pesticides after youve used the
pesticide change your clothes
immediately wash your gloves hat face
shield and Boots every day and check
gloves for
leaks never store or wash work clothing
with the family
laundry be sure to read and follow the
directions on pesticide labels exactly
otherwise pesticides can be
lethal breathing Vapors or skin contact
is one of the most common methods of
pesticide poisoning pesticides can enter
your skin in Greater amounts than you
could swallow or inhale
pesticide drifts can be dangerous so
when mixing and pouring pesticides keep
them below eye level and work with the
wind to your side operate equipment so
that the pesticide drift is away from
you keep unauthorized people and
children away when using pesticides this
will help avoid accidental eating or
drinking know the signs and symptoms of
pesticide poisoning so that first aid
can be administered
immediately a person with mild pesticide
poisoning will exhibit signs of fatigue
headache dizziness blurred vision
excessive sweating nausea vomiting
stomach cramps and
diarrhea moderate pesticide poisoning
will include all of these symptoms plus
the inability to walk weakness chest
discomfort muscle twitches and
constriction of
pupils with severe poisoning the person
will become unconscious experience
severe pupil constriction muscle
twitches secretions from the mouth and
nose and difficulty breathing if
pesticide poisoning occurs call the
paramedics immediately then read the
label for any first aid information
pesticide labels contain practical
treatment
information if skin contact has been
made remove the pesticide quickly if the
pesticide has been splashed in the mouth
or swallowed rinse the mouth out
immediately pesticides can be used
safely if labels are red proper
equipment and protective clothing is
worn and directions are followed
precisely p pesticide users must also
take their environment into
consideration when wind drifts occur the
pesticide is moved outside of the target
area and can be harmful to non-target
plants animals water and people do not
apply pesticides in moderate or strong
winds use a low pressure spray to avoid
drift pesticide runoff can kill fish and
wildlife and leech through the soil
contaminating
groundwater one of the most important
ways you can protect your environment is
with the careful storage and
transportation of
pesticides the recommended way to carry
pesticides is to place the container in
a plastic tub or bucket this tub should
be large enough to hold the contents of
the original container should it leak or
break secure the plastic tub in the bed
of a pickup truck store pesticides in
its original labeled container the
storage building should have a cement
floor always store pesticides away from
water or streams always store pesticides
in a cool dry place out of direct
sunlight if pesticides are spilled can
find the spill by building a dyke or by
soaking up the spill with sawdust or
soil once soaked up shovel into a leak
proof container for disposal into a
special pesticide landfill wash
containers at least three times before
disposal all containers must be
destroyed or buried after
use pesticide use is a safe and simple
way to control pests just remember that
the most common mistake in pesticide use
is made by ignoring one or two safety
procedures or pieces of equipment every
procedure and piece of equipment listed
on the label is
important as long as they are properly
used pesticides will help produce
plentiful healthy crops today and in the
future
[Music]
the preceding was a production of New
Mexico State University the views and
opinions in this program are those of
the author and do not necessarily
represent the views and opinions of the
NMSU Board of regions